my name is alex and i'm here uh from
d-wave systems to talk to you about
practical quantum computing today
uh for those of you who aren't familiar
with d-wave systems uh we're a canadian
company i'm actually in vancouver which
is part of the reason that traveling
across the border was a bit tough these
days
and we've been building quantum
computing quantum computers for the last
20 years
um before i get
too far into my talk i want to start off
by saying that
most of the stuff i'm going to be
talking about a lot of the information
is available either in open source or in
leap which is our cloud platform for
quantum computing
and i also want to mention that it's
really important to us that we get
feedback from folks like you all
you know the quantum computing industry
for a long time has been an industry of
physicists but increasingly with the
power of quantum computing increasing
and our ability to access you know real
practical problems it's increasingly
becoming a community of developers and
data scientists and project managers and
operations researchers and all of the
different folks who are making use of
these products rather than just the ones
who are building it and so getting
feedback from folks like you
is really crucial to our ability to
continue to provide
practical value uh to customers and to
users
and to that end uh we have an online
community that you can get involved in
we are also
present on github
and you know those sorts of comments
questions
issues pull requests all that fun stuff
is really really really important to us
and and we really really value it so you
know please feel free uh to comment and
all that and i'll also be taking
questions at the end of the talk
okay
so uh let's get started so the first
thing that you're going to need if you
want to do practical quantum computing
is you're going to need a quantum
computer
there are a wide variety of different
flavors of quantum computers that are
available you know in the world today so
there are annealing systems there are
circuit model systems there are
topological systems these are sort of
different models for quantum computing
and then there's also different
implementations so there's trapped ion
systems and there's photonic systems and
they're super conducting systems
we at d-wave build a particular type of
quantum computer which is a quantum
annealer so it's an annealing based qpu
we also build it on top of
superconducting circuits so our
fabrication process you know uses a lot
of the same sorts of fabrication
processes that you use to print
classical chips which has been a really
big advantage for us
and the reason that we build a quantum
annealer specifically and we use
superconducting metal is because it's
really important to we think it's the
fastest way to make it practically
useful to users today
now reasonable reasonable minds can and
do disagree on what the sort of earliest
path to uh to you know quantum computing
relevance is but this is the one that we
think is the one that's gonna that is
able to provide value today
and one of some of the advantages of the
type of processor that we make and the
type of fabrication that we use is that
it allows us to scale uh to a relevant
to a customer relevant scale uh
relatively easily and so for instance
right now our system has about 5 000
qubits and about 35 000 couplers which
means that uh we have quite a few you
know quite a bit more qubits than than
some of the other uh models um but and
we also have about a 15 degree
connectivity between our qubits so each
of our qubits can interact with 15 other
qubits which again is uh really
important to to be able to express
complex problems that you want to solve
on that system
so
to give you a sense of like what the
what goes into having one of these
systems what goes into maintaining it
what goes into uh using it i want to
talk a little bit about the hardware um
and so on that left hand most picture
you can see a image it's the same image
from the last slide of one of our uh
boxes essentially that lives in our lab
here in burnaby outside of vancouver
to give you sort of a sense of scale
it's about the size of a pretty good
sized bathroom um on the front of it is
you can sort of see that there's a set
of server racks you know again
that's about a little bit shorter than a
person
and we use those sort of classical
servers to drive the quantum computer
i'm actually going to be talking about
that a little bit later
um this whole box is really designed to
create an isolated environment for the
quantum computation itself
and so if you were to crack open that
that box uh you know and you were to
step inside the faraday cage and the
first level of refrigeration uh and you
know and over all of the vibration
dampers and all that fun stuff what you
would see is this middle picture uh
which is called the chandelier um this
is actually like a picture of uh naked
chandelier we've removed all the various
containers um if you actually were to
open the box what you would see is a big
cylinder and then if you open that
cylinder you would see another cylinder
inside and so on and so forth a series
of sort of nesting dolls
and each of these cylinders is an
increasingly isolated environment so at
the sort of outermost cylinder it's
operating about 50 kelvin so that's
still you know negative 200 degrees it's
still very very cold and fairly isolated
but as we get further and further into
the system it gets colder and colder and
more and more isolated so down to four
kelvin or one kelvin or 100 millikelvin
which is already 2 degrees colder than
interstellar space and all the way down
to 15 millikelvin which is the operating
temperature of a superconducting quantum
computer and is literally one of the
coldest places in the universe
at the very bottom of that chandelier is
what you see on the right hand side
which is our sample holder so the sample
holder is about the size of maybe your
hand
and that's where you know the quantum
computer starts to interface with the
various electronics that
that control it
so in and in the very very middle of
that sample holder is a little thumbnail
size stamp and that's the actual quantum
computer
so this is actually another picture of
that sample holder um this time with a
little bit more zoomed in
um and and you know as i said this whole
thing's about the size of your hand and
in the middle that little uh you know
olive green square that's the quantum
computer
i'm not actually sure how good the
resolution is in the room that y'all are
in um but uh you might actually even be
able to see on that square that there's
a little bit of structure you can sort
of see there's kind of like a maybe a
bit of a grid like structure those are
the qubits and those are the controls
that power that that drive the qubits
okay so uh now we're going to have to
pass out of pictures and into sort of a
more abstract representation
um and start talking about the way that
our qubits are
laid out and the way that our qubits
interact with each other
so at the sort of this is a
representation of the layout of our
qubits each of these white
bars
is a cupid and in fact they're not a bar
uh they're actually a loop they're like
a long elongated stretched out oval
and they're an oval that's made up of
superconducting metal
and the reason that we do this is
because
if you keep that metal at 50 ml kelvin
which we do
and you put a strong uh magnetic field
sort of through the loop you can cause
current to travel around the loop both
clockwise and anti-clockwise at the same
time
and that creates superposition which is
required if you want to be doing quantum
computing you want to start your uh your
problem in superposition
and then uh in addition to the cubit
bodies so each of these sorts of little
ovals um
or long bars they also interact with
each other via coupler so you can see
sort of where they butt up against each
other or where they cross each other
those are the places where these qubits
can interact with each other and the
couplers uh can either are fairly
straightforward they either enforce sort
of an equality relationship or an
inequality relationship amongst humans
overall we lay the qubits out in what we
call a pegasus graph which is the the
sort of structure that you can see a
snapshot of in this picture i won't
spend too much time on it other than to
say we picked it very carefully because
it allows you to
print these qubits which have sort of
physical size limits in a way that is
highly connected to other qubits and in
a way that uh can solve really difficult
problems
okay uh we're almost done with the
physics uh but i i i had to end with uh
one
final sort of physics e slide and this
is probably the most uh the most physics
that i'll get
this equation is what defines the
state of the quantum computer over the
course of the anneal and i actually want
to hone in on a particular part of it
this sort of right hand side
this this part of the equation is called
the quantum machine instruction and this
is the piece that if i'm programming the
system i'm generally controlling so when
we say we want to program a quantum
computer what we're generally saying is
that we want to control this part of the
dynamics of the system and specifically
what i can control are the h i
and the j i j terms in this two second
degree polynomial so i can bias with the
h i the individual qubits and i can bias
the interaction between cubis with the j
i
j what this this problem is quantum
machine instruction actually is in the
parlance of optimization or operations
research or computer science this is
known as a binary quadratic model
and just to sort of walk through that in
a little bit of detail um
the reason we call it a binary quadratic
model is that first off our qubits can
be thought of as binary variables
so i mentioned earlier that in the that
we start off with we can put our qubits
into superposition
but at the end of the computation our
qubits actually have the current either
going clockwise or anticlockwise so it's
not both anymore it's one or the other
at the end of the computation
that corresponds to a binary variable
i also mentioned that we can couple our
qubits we can moderate their
interactions that's a quadratic
interaction that's what the jij
terminates that's the uh second degree
polynomial aspect of this equation and
then finally i mentioned that you can
moderate the qubits individually that's
the linear objective that's the h i
sigma z
and i'm actually going to talk a little
bit so if that part was a little bit uh
physically don't worry about it we're
going to talk about that a little bit
more later and hopefully make that a
little bit more intuitive
and so in order to sort of
make this a bit clearer hopefully and to
give you a sense of some of the problems
that you can solve on the system
i'm going to talk about a very
particular problem that is in some sense
natively solved on the quantum computer
specifically i'm going to be solving
talking about a problem of structural
imbalance
so the problem statement is this
imagine that i have a network of agents
they could be people they could be
companies they could be social media
profiles they could be
governments they could be organizations
you know
entities
and then each of these entities exists
in something called a signed social
network which is to say they can either
have friendly or hostile relationships
amongst each other
and on this picture
i have a group of six agents and i have
denoted them as either having friendly
relationships with a teal uh line
between them or hostile relationships
with a orange line between them
the goal of structural imbalance
problems in general is to divide up
these agents these people in such a way
that avoids
frustration and to define frustration
what i mean is that let's say i took all
six of these people and i put them on a
team together
there'd probably be a little bit of
problems because you know there's
there's at least four hostile
relationships on that team in fact
there's as many hostile relationships as
there are friendly relationships and
that's sort of forcing everybody to work
together despite there being hostility
that's frustration
i'll also mention that frustration has
like a mathematical and physics and
computer science definition and it's not
actually that different than what i've
described it's that sort of um
non-optimality in a solution
so if i wanted to solve this problem on
a quantum computer
i need to be able to formulate it as a
quantum machine instruction and
therefore a binary quadratic model
so the binary quadratic model
formulation of this problem is that
rather than putting all of my agents
onto the same team i'm going to put them
onto one of two teams let's say on the
left or right side of a river or you
know the the red team and the blue team
shirts and skins whatever you wanna
whatever you wanna do
and so when i if i want to find the
configuration for these agents that's
minimally frustrated to solve this on a
quantum computer i can represent each of
these agents as a i can use a qubit to
represent each of these agents and i
told you that those qubits can represent
binary variables which in this case are
going to correspond to say the left side
or the right side of the river
i also have relationships amongst these
variables which is that they're either
friendly or hostile which again i
mentioned earlier that are cubits we can
couple them we can either force them to
agree or to disagree that's a friendly
or hostile relationship
and then i also said that you know we
have linear objectives but in this case
we don't really care we could use a
linear objective for instance to sort of
favor one side of the river or the other
there's other things you could imagine
doing but in this case it's not really
that applicable so i'll just mention
that it exists and and move on
so if i actually want to represent this
problem as a binary quadratic model in
the mathematical sense this is the
equation that defines that relationship
and again you know if this is a little
bit uh into the weeds don't worry about
it it's not that important other than to
say that to compare that to this quantum
machine instruction if you kind of
squint at it you can see that they are
both second-degree polynomials you know
the s's become the sigmas and they have
a similar form and so you can kind of
imagine how you might get from one of
these forms into the other and that is
really the game that that we at d-wave
are in or at least my part of the
company which is transforming these sort
of more abstract problems like structure
imbalance into something that can be
solved on the quantum computer
and that actually lets me introduce the
next thing that you're going to need if
you want to do practical quantum
computing so so far i've talked about
you need a quantum computer that seems
kind of uh obvious you need some
problems to solve that seems kind of
obvious but what you're also going to
need if you haven't thought about it is
you're going to need hybrid solvers
so what i mean when i say hybrid is i
mean algorithms that combine the best of
both quantum and classical resources
together to get the best of both worlds
classical computing has been around now
for you know 50 to 100 years there's
been a lot of thought a lot of effort a
lot of development a lot of hardware
development a lot of algorithm
development that has gone into it and
all of those things uh are useful we
quantum computing will not change the
fact that classical computing is
incredibly powerful for certain classes
of problems and so if you want to be
solving practical problems you need to
be thinking about doing both together
one of the other things that hybrid
solvers give us is the ability to solve
more abstract problems than the binary
quadratic model that i mentioned earlier
you can specify other types of problems
so to carry on with the example we were
doing
imagine that now i want to divide up my
social network into three locations
let's say the pub the plaza and the
church
now i don't have binary variables
anymore remember my quantum computer
solves binary problems so how do i
handle this
well the answer is is that you can use
hybrid solvers so there are solvers that
use a classical component and then use
the quantum computer to accelerate parts
of the computation and our pla and our
hybrid solvers can can solve these more
abstract problems so for instance i can
divide my network between the pub the
plaza and the church
so in this case this problem class is
now called a discrete quadratic model so
it has the same quadratic and linear
aspect but instead of having binary
variables it has discrete variables pub
plaza church you could also imagine red
blue yellow or or much higher numbers i
could have plaza church pub restaurant
theater
house you know you can have much higher
numbers
the next type of thing that you might
want to do is you might want to take it
even another uh level up and for those
of you in the audience who have you know
maybe a bit of operations research or or
something like that um you're probably
going to recognize right away um you
want to be able to add constraints so i
want to so so far i've been solving
so-called unconstrained problems i've
just said minimize the frustration i
don't really have any rules other than
are imposed by the variable type
here i can add additional constraints i
can add additional rules to my problem
so for instance i can say i want to have
at least three people in the plaza
so here i'm combining my discrete
variables plaza pub and church i'm if
i'm adding my quadratic interactions
hostile or friendly
and i'm adding a constraint which is
that you can i want no fewer than three
people in the plaza
and so by sort of marching up this
complexity tree you can express more and
more types of problems at a higher and
higher level and i will mention that
when we work with customers and we help
them solve their problems this level
this constrained quadratic model level
is the level that we generally are
working at um that's the level in which
we are you know talking to some of the
logistics companies that i'll be talking
about later and some of the different
things that we use to solve problems
so just to give you a little bit of a
flavor of some of the types of problems
that we solve and some of the types of
problems that we've worked on
we've worked with bvda in financial
services so there we were doing
portfolio optimization and forecasting
we've worked with save on foods which is
the canadian grocer not the texas
pressure um to do scheduling and
logistics problems we worked with vw
where we routed uh buses at a conference
and we've also looked worked on various
manufacturing and logistics problems
internal to their business and then
we've also done sort of life sciences
and materials discovery so we worked
with a company called menton ai to do de
novo protein design and these are just a
small smattering of a very large set of
different applications that we've worked
on and have been put into production
okay
before i sort of move on to the next
thing i also want to just give you spend
a little bit more time talking about
hybrid algorithms because they're so
important and i want to give you a
little bit of a flavor of some of the
types of hybrid algorithms and what goes
into creating a hybrid algorithm and the
reason i want to do that is it's cool b
it's the thing that i'm interested in
and see you know this is the place where
computer scientists really provide a lot
of value i mean my team is predominantly
uh computer scientists electrical
engineers machine learners you know uh
robotics engineers all that sort of
stuff folks who aren't uh phys aren't
physicists generally because we are in
the business of defining and creating
these hybrid algorithms
so the simplest form of a hybrid
algorithm and the first one that most
people think of when they try to think
of a way to use a quantum computer in
the context of a very large computation
is decomposition and what i mean by that
is taking a problem that's too big for
the quantum computer grabbing chunks of
it solving those chunks on the quantum
computer reincorporating those chunks
into the solution space and carrying on
this is in some sense the simplest
possible hybrid algorithm and you know
it's an oldie but a goodie
the next type of hybrid algorithm i want
to talk about is pre-processing
this is using a classical algorithm to
pre-process a problem before submitting
it to a quantum computer so for instance
often you can do various types of
pre-processing to make a problem smaller
or harder or
you know to filter out some some noise
all of these sorts of things are very
well done classically and can be done
before submitting to the quantum
computer
the inverse of that is also true you can
use a quantum computer to see a
classical algorithm
one of the things i haven't spent a
whole lot of time talking about is you
know
where is the niche for the quantum
computer specifically and i can tell you
uh you know in sort of a fast way that
the quantum computer finds pretty good
solutions pretty fast and i mean that
sounds kind of
fuzzy maybe but it's actually quite
powerful because a lot of classical
algorithms will find perfect solutions
but they take a very long time and so if
you can use the quantum computer to find
a pretty good solution pretty fast and
use that to seed a classical algorithm
you can accelerate that classical
algorithm's overall run time pretty
significantly and in fact most of the
time when we're doing direct work on the
qpu that's what we're doing
okay
so so far i've said you need a quantum
computer i've said you need problems to
solve i've said you need hybrid
algorithms and then there's one more
thing well a couple more things but one
more big thing that you're going to need
if you're going to want to solve
practical quantum computing companies
you need to be able to access the thing
so we have a bunch of these systems
sitting in burnaby uh here outside of
vancouver we have a couple more in north
america and other places um and
those sitting there in the lab aren't
that useful if you don't have cloud
access you need a rest api you need an
ability for users to access it and in
addition to that if you have a rest api
and you have access from from the
external world you're going to need uh
queuing systems you're going to need
authentication you're going to need
databases you're going to need all of
the different things that allow you to
have sort of a cloud provided resource
and then on top of all of that you're
going to need an interface you're going
to need users going to need to be able
to construct problems they're going to
need to be able to submit them from
their libraries of choice they're going
to need different ways of understanding
what's going on on the system and so all
of these different aspects are
incredibly important to making quantum
computing actually useful to users and
so you know that's why d-wave in
addition to being a quantum computing
company we're also a cloud company
because we need to create all of that
infrastructure you can't just rent time
on a quantum computer in an aws
part we had to create all of that
infrastructure
and then you know
to sort of harp on one specific thing
that's very near dear to my heart um
you're also going to need a uh
client-side libraries and so d-wave has
the ocean open source python tools which
are where people can construct problems
for the quantum computer
um our tools are python interfaces so uh
but with c plus plus under the hood i
think a lot of different scientific
computing
organizations are doing this way where
uh you know somehow the scientific
computing computing community has
decided python is the language and yet
uh we need more performance so we're all
doing c plus under the hood funny world
we live in um it's open source so that
you know folks can actually understand
how we're doing some of the steps that i
talked about earlier and you know we
allow flexible installation and all of
this is pre-configured and can be used
right away in our online ide which i'll
mention i'll show in just a moment
okay so that's been a lot of slides
probably a little bit of physics some
operations research but you know they
say that a demo is worth a thousand
slides so in order to sort of finish
this off i just want to give you a bit
of a sense of what it looks like to
access a quantum computer in the cloud
because after all this is a cloud so
i'll just stop shooting my screen for
one second
and i'll exit like this and i'll switch
things
let's try that hopefully you all can see
this
um so
this is if you were to sign up for a
free leap account which any of you can
do anytime um you'll get free access to
a quantum computer and free access to
our hybrid solvers this is what you this
is the page that you would land on
um and i don't have time to go through
sort of all of this in all of its flurry
and all the details but you know just to
give you a very quick tour you can see
problems that you've submitted you can
see the different resources that have
available so you can see the quantum
computers that you have available as
well as the hybrid solvers
i mean then we have a bunch of different
resources so for instance we have a
bunch of illustrated demos and
specifically that problem that i was
describing before
with science social networks you can you
can we have an illustrated demo around
this that i've
adapted for the purpose of this
presentation so you can for instance see
the science social network you can see
it being divided into two rivers romeo
and juliet
and you can start learning about
frustration and then finally um you know
you can see how uh in romeo and juliet
there is no way to create an
unfrustrated problem
and then finally you can learn about how
we uh program this problem directly onto
the quantum computer
i'll also mention that you know if you
have particular applications that you're
interested in understanding how you
might solve using a quantum computer we
have a set of examples and you know
there's lots of different examples of
different sorts of problem classes but
i'm going to continue on the science
social network theme
and give that a click uh here if you
open that up you can go check out how we
solve that problem on github or you can
open this up in our online integrated
developer environment which is uh an
online place that we've pre-installed
everything that you need in order to
access uh quantum computing so it has
ocean our open source tools it has your
access to the quantum computer
pre-configured it has all the libraries
that you need to to have installed and
really everything that you need it's a
full featured ide
um and then the last thing that i'll
just you know mention is that
one of the reasons that we've done this
is in order to make this
easier for users to understand how the
quantum computer is getting involved so
for instance i can i can solve that same
structural imbalance problem that i was
talking about before
and i'm going to solve it on the qpu
and
in this case let's say that i'm
interested in how did i map this
structural imbalance to the quantum
computer so what i've just done is i've
just kicked off our script this is
actually making use of our quantum
computer in real time it's submitting
the problem uh it's being run through
our rest api through our cloud system uh
it's being run on a quantum computer in
burnaby which i still think is pretty
cool and when we do that uh we can use
our inspector to get a sense of like
what this problem looked like when
mapped to the quantum computer
so on the left hand side here you can
actually see sort of a image of our
social network this one's quite a bit
bigger than the one that i
was showing before with the six agents
this one has a couple hundred
um and i can see for instance here's the
solutions to the social network problem
that the quantum computer found but to
me the cool part is that you can also
see how this problem was mapped directly
onto the quantum computer so on the
right hand side of the screen you
actually see that in this case we used
one of our 2000 qubit systems not our
5000 qubit system
but you can see how the different agents
i mentioned earlier that the agents in
the graph can be mapped to individual
qubits
and you can actually see that so
variable agent 417 was mapped to qubit
969.
so in real time you can actually
understand how this problem was mapped
to the quantum computer and how this
problem was um solved and then finally
because quantum computing can be a
little bit uh confusing and it's still
relatively you know early days um we
also throw you know sort of like
essentially compiler warnings that can
give you hints uh about what might have
gone wrong in your solving process
um and so you know in this case all of
these things are actually fine otherwise
we wouldn't have made this a demo but
nonetheless they're sort of interesting
and you can you can learn different
aspects of the quantum computer
the last thing that i'm just going to
show i'm just going to mention uh in
leap just uh to finish this off is that
we have a bunch of different resources
and we have a community and so i want to
end this this sort of talk by uh
simply restating what i said at the
beginning which is that it's really
important to us that you all you know
give us feedback let us know what's
useful we really want to make our
quantum computer useful for for business
and and the best way that we can do that
is to get developers like y'all uh and
folks like you all involved in helping
us with that process
uh and so finally i think yeah my last
slide was just to say thank you um and i
am happy to take any questions i also
realize i talked a little fast which is
easy to do when you're talking on zoom
so maybe i'll stop sharing and i'll pull
up
slack
all right so
i think you can i don't 100 sure how
this works but i think there's a mic you
can walk up to maybe and or you can put
questions in slack i'm happy to answer
them uh to go
um i see one question in the slack which
maybe i'll start off with which is uh
the thing i'm most curious about with
quantum computing is what's an example
of a simple program that can be
expressed on a quantum computer that
can't easily be expressed on a classical
computer
so
there's a difference between expression
and
solving
so
there as far as i know there's no proof
that you could say solve the halting
problem on a quantum computer and what
that means is that in terms of your
ability to express
i don't know of any problems that can't
be expressed on either
it's much more a function of
what is the better platform to solve it
on and you know
we actually have a classical analog
right now which is we have cpus and we
have gpus and then you know you're also
starting to see tensor processing units
and vector processing units and other
things and there's no problem that a gpu
can solve that a class a cpu can't solve
or vice versa it's just that one is much
better than the other in its particular
problem domain now quantum computers
have some different complexities than
classical computers so gpus and cpus
exist in the same complexity class
quantum computers have their own
complexity class so in some ways it's
different but there isn't really a
problem that can't be expressed
in terms of problems that can't be
solved um i would have to point you to
the google supremacy result from a few
years ago there's some controversy
around was that really a supremacy
resulted it'll take a little time for
that to shake out but it doesn't make it
it's still a very cool scientific result
of a example of a problem that
can't be solved classically it can be
expressed but not solved or at least not
within
reasonable timelines um
so yeah i hope that answers the question
i'm happy to follow up if there's if
there's more questions about that
can i ill oh sorry great question um so
can i illustrate how a frustration
problem manifests in real world
applications um
that's an awesome question so
let's imagine for a moment that i have
an unfrustrated problem so i'm gonna
solve a social science social networking
problem um where
everybody is friends
there's no there's no hostility at all
and i want to assign my agents to one of
two teams in such a way that friends
play together and enemies play across
different teams well that problem's
trivial right like i just i place
somebody on a team and then i put their
friend on their team and then they're
their friend on their team and i just
carry on and there's no
difficulty in that problem because
there's no trade-offs there's no um
there's no difficulty to it
whereas in a highly frustrated problem
frustration really just means trade-offs
like i'm having to balance between
these two
people uh liking each other being really
good friends and then but they both
don't like this other person and how do
you work that out so
real difficult problems in industry are
frustrated i'll also mention for those
of you who have the sort of um
the comp you know who are comfortable
with complexity theory that np-hard
problems are frustrating problems if
they're unfrustrated you can generally
solve them linearly or at least
polynomially whereas frustrated problems
are are exactly um exponential problems
so so really all of the hard problems
that people want to solve day in day out
are frustrated so again if i uh it's
hard to tell if i answered your question
rex i can't actually see you to like see
if you're nodding or you're looking at
me like i'm crazy so feel free to follow
up in slack if i
uh if i um didn't get that right
um
next question is there a book i'd
recommend for understanding the basic
principles of quantum computing in an
intuitive way for those with a
background in undergraduate physics and
math rigorous enough to be a gateway to
the future learning but not too heavy at
first
that is a great question to wish i
really which i really wish i had a nice
hat answer there isn't one book that i'd
recommend although i'll have to think
about that i will say i mean it's kind
of a um
there's a there's a business answer
which i do mean which is like we do have
a bunch of great resources on our
website a bunch of white papers for
getting started which is where i would
start um
and then similarly i'll also mention for
those of you who are interested in
quantum computing writ large all of the
different uh vendors so you know there's
us and there's ibm and there's google
and there's xanadu and regetty and some
and some others um we all are trying
very hard to educate the public as much
as possible so if you're interested in
doing like practical quantum computing i
would actually start with the various
vendors rather than with textbooks
because
the
the
academic community sort of by its nature
is turning out a lot of really amazing
research but
it's a little bit more focused on the
theoretical side whereas the vendors who
are trying to actually build these
things and make it useful for business i
mean we're laser focused on how do we
make this useful now now now now and so
in general my advice would be to start
with the vendors if you're interested in
getting more more resources
hi alex can i jump in with a live
question
yeah of course great um thank you for
the talk um i was just curious if the
hardware that you showed us today
allows you to also think about quantum
error correction in addition to solving
problems via annealing
yeah that's a great question um
the short answer is
in the annealing model you don't really
need quantum error correction in the
same way that you do in a circuit model
or gate model system
so our system starts off in
superposition sort of in a coherence
regime and then it ends the computation
in the classical regime so it doesn't
need to stay coherent throughout the
entire computation
and so as that's an advantage to us
because uh it means that you need you
don't need error correction in the same
way now
that said
many of the same
principles and aspects of fabrication do
apply to quantum annealing it's actually
the the fabrication and the actual
implementation of the systems are much
more similar than i think a lot of
people realize um so
even though the particular model that
we've implemented
doesn't doesn't really use that concept
wholesale it does use a lot of the
underlying concepts and um
yeah maybe i'll just leave it at that
for now although i will mention that we
have our
conference starting uh next week where
we're announcing some really cool new
stuff um which uh unfortunately i can't
talk about because we're a whole like
three days earlier but i would really
encourage you to check that out when we
when we talk about it in about three or
four days
we have time for one more question
uh should i read one off slack or
yeah sure okay um how quickly did the
qpu solve the example that you demoed uh
ignoring the overhead of setting the
problem from your browser to the
computer said differently how quick is
the qp clock cycle that even a valid
question uh great question um so the
problem that i solved was solved in the
actual annealing time the amount of time
on the quantum computer itself was about
10 microseconds
um uh sorry yeah microseconds um and the
programming time so the amount of time
that the that it took for the classical
computer that drives the quantum
computer was about 100 milliseconds so
just to give you a sense of the sort of
scales um
what that means in practice is that when
we solve a problem we don't just solve
it once because the programming time is
like 100 milliseconds and then the
actual solving time is microseconds so
we actually do like hundreds or even
thousands of solves otherwise you've
kind of wasted that 100 milliseconds you
know this the scales are off um so
actually that in that demo i showed i
think we solved that problem a thousand
times um so that would be a thousand
times you know 10 microseconds so i
think unfortunately that's the last
question i'll be in the slack for a
little bit longer so i'm happy to answer
more questions there thank you so much
for watching my talk and putting up with
me calling in from from burnaby uh this
has been really fun and great questions
and enjoy the rest of the conference
[Music]
you